WONDE
YNTHE DID GIVE A YOUR LUT AAND
TAOUH IN THE
SOLIDITY OF THE DEMOLSPPENEDCE
>> YOU STILL FEEL THAT WAYELWIN
FIGURE D
SUTING.
ITEPTH OF IV OF
PEOPLE AROUND THEFANY BELIEF-
THAT GO INTOAKCRACY S  INDEPENDC
.
I THINK IT IS INDISPUTABLE T
DEWE HAVE SEEN A BACKLASH DEMOC
IDEALS AROUND  NOT UNIQUE TO AN
PLACE, IT ED
EUROPE AND, IT
PPENED IN THIS PART OF
THWOTHE
IN ASIA. NEAN, IT ISAPPENING
AS I MEET PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD, THERE IS STILL A
FUN THE D
INALS, ATHEIR ENCY IN DETEIN
I THTHAT'S NG PEOPLE WA. BUT OU
INSTITUTIONS ARE CREAKY, REFOR
. ALCREAKY
OR NOT INSTITUTIONS IN T
UNITED STATES.
ECTACLR ESIDENT BEING FEEDWAS T
WORLD,EMOCRAD FACT THAT A RA
AE IGOFFICE IN THE THE D?
-- INDIBTEE. >>ER ], BUT THE T
IS HAVING  ANSWETO C
AND THE ALLEGATIONS WILL NOW BET
PRES
ITED STATES  O THE
EXISTING LAWS, BUT MORE BROAHE
E DI WHETHER I TRY
CHANGES IN LLA,
REBL DON'T THE PREA RANTDE SENT
THINIT IS SOTHO  THINKTHERS LE
S THAT DON'TAND
THE
IDEAS, THE IA
WETHE RULES OF
OU ALWAYS THE
ONEST E, WE E BY THE RUS,HAS WE
SI OFFICE AND
NEED TO STRENG THEM AGAIN.
>> NEED ASK AOLUPAT IT ISAID T
OCRACYREENOUGH TO SURVIVA ONE ID
PERSONALITY WINS? ANSPECULE  TH
OUOF AUTURE ELECTI
HAVING BEEN PRESIDENT OF T HE O
UNITED STATES, YOU NEE
PRESIDENWHKEF CE SERIOUSLYES NOJ
IN THE LETTEBUT IN
DEMOCRACY. L Y ISAS PRESIDENT
OF T UNITED STATES YOU ARE
JUE OF THESERIES OCOCHCES
YOU CAN'T NOTHE NORMS.
GUARD LL PN
ISN'T WHAT DESUTIONS RIS THEINT
MECHISOBLEMS. E GOOD NEWS IS
ICAN PEOE
PO
LIICE  I DO THINK
THHAPPENS IN THE
SURPRISED U ING I'
KNEW GOING
I KNEW THATHE
AN EXTORLYFUL  OF AMERIC THE IS
ELIGIOUS LARGE BIGLITESTILL BEI
ABLE TO FUNCTIMO AIMT
E D,
LIKE AMERICA'S DRAETERING, AND
WORLD, IT WORRIES D  ATIC F IT
THE ERPIECE  HIS  THREATSBYDICTU
ERAL DEMOCRACY AS WELL.
WHO  CONSIDEAUTOCRATIC O A ICTAT
LIBE. E
THE PRESIDENT ENGAGE
WISE KINDSS,
EIE RS, > COLLOCATED, WHEN I
PRESIDENT, I WOULDGURES, IN SOM
, WHO IFIN IVATE, DO  RUN THEIR
VERNMENTS D THEI
SAY ARE EAATIC? I
I HAVE TSANOOU HAVE TO DO BUH T
NAS. E ARE OFINTERES, WITH
INTHAT   TO GEACCORDS DONE, CL
TRENNY
MOMENTARY ISSUES, ISROAT ER
NK IT  APPROPRFOR THPR TWHSHE C
HOSE LESE
DOORS, T ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THITED STATES,
CED IN
REUO
ES
MEETS WITHME MINISTER,
AND THOTON OF THAT.
THE  MINITIN AMAJORI AO AREA, VH
KNOW
WELL, PART OF O NOT PROTECT THES
MINORITIES IN INDIA,
THEN THERE IS A NG
PO
TARTS PULLING APART.S WH
G THOSE KINDS
LARGE .
THE RESTS,